bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 21 juin
vous regardez le 7 8 le journal merci de
nous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
édition comme chaque jour nous revenons
sur votre actualité locale entouré de
nous inviter mais également des
journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite on commence avec les titres c'est
une mesure proposée par valérie pécresse
la présidente de la région ile de france
la hausse du tarif du pass navigo une
proposition justifiée par les 300
millions d'euros que la région devrait
verser au syndicat de transport afin de
compenser le manque à gagner du
dispositif tarifaire lancée par
l'ancienne majorité
françois hollande a inauguré vendredi
dernier le pavillon dufour du château de
versailles
après un vaste chantier de réaménagement
le nouvel espace d'accueil du public se
veut plus esthétiques et fonctionnels
dont vous le feront découvrir et coup
d'envoi des soldes c'est demain les
commerçants sont en plein préparatifs
pour ses six semaines de réduction une
période cruciale pour eux qui pourrait
compenser la tendance des mauvaises
ventes dû à la météo font aujourd'hui 21
juin c'est la fête de la musique c'est
donc ce soir pour célébrer l'arrivée de
l'été et espérons le du soleil plusieurs
rendez vous sont proposées sur le
territoire à montigny le bretonneux
voisins le bretonneux où les
clayes-sous-bois de nombreux concerts
auront lieu dès 19 heures dans les
villes de saint quentin en yvelines
le domaine national de port royal des
champs se met lui aussi à la musique de
20h à 22h30 deux concerts sont organisés
sur le site de l'abbaye
au programme une virée à broadway à
broadway pardon avec un quatuor vocal a
cappella suivi d'un concert de jazz du
bernard vidal et rio un feu de la
saint-jean sera allumé pour clore à
cette soirée
l'entrée est libre et c'est
l'association pour le rayonnement de
port royal des champs qui organise cette
soirée en partenariat avec le musée
on écoute maintenant un mot à propos des
artistes recueillis au micro de camille
lambert
on a choisi ces artistes là parce que
quatuor vocal à répéter ici plusieurs
fois donc c'est une façon de soutenir
des jeunes et les mares on a eu la
chance de vous pouvoir venir en
résidence une semaine début avril pour
créer entièrement ce spectacle car le
répéter vocalement sur la scène et c'est
sur la scène sur laquelle on va jouer ce
soir on est partie du répertoire de
broadway et du off broadway et puis on a
créé un certain nombre d'arrangements
autour d'une petite histoire ont fait
voyager au gré des grands airs ou des
petits there un petit peu caché de
broadway et nous vous en parlions dans
l'édition du journal d'hier le pass
navigo mensuel risque d'augmenter c'est
une mesure proposée par valérie pécresse
est la présidente de la région ile de
france
actuellement à 70 euros une taxe de 10 à
15 euros serait d'appliquer si le
gouvernement ne développe pas les fonds
nécessaires au financement du tarif
unique selon variae valérie pécresse qui
organisait hier une table ronde pour
présenter son plan de financement c'est
environ 300 millions d'euros que la
région devrait verser au stif pour
compenser le manque à gagner du nouveau
dispositif tarifaire les précisions avec
william l appliquer une taxe valls c'est
la mesure proposée par valérie pécresse
pour financer le pass navigo à tarif
unique mis en place par son prédécesseur
selon la présidente de la région ile de
france le coût du forfait mensuel
s'élèverait à 450 millions d'euros
chaque année pour le stif 150 millions
d'euros seraient remboursés par
l'augmentation d'une taxe payée par les
employeurs
le reste n'aurait pour le moment pas de
plan de financement
moi je n'ai pas du tout envie
d'augmenter le bassin niveau mais si
l'état ne tient pas ses engagements si
manuel valls se tient pas ses promesses
nous serons obligés de mettre en place
une taxe valse 10 à 15 euros pour
financer le pass navigo pour continuer
d'acheter du matériel roulant neuf pour
mettre plus de sécurité pour mettre des
nouveaux
sur les lignes parce que les franciliens
sont trop vagues transporté aujourd'hui
le pass navigo à tarif unique aurait
favorisé l'augmentation du nombre
d'abonnés mais aurait fait baisser les
recettes de vente de billets à l'unité
la mesure elle est contestée par
l'opposition
le premier signal de la transition
écologique c'est le coup de bambou sur
le pouvoir d'achat des franciliens qui
souhaitent se déplacer soit pour leurs
loisirs soit pour aller travailler
regardez bien je vous le dis regardez
bien que dans le même temps on augmente
les crédits routiers c'est à dire que
les lobbys de la voiture le finalement
les des promesses de campagne de
monsieur dupont-aignan pourquoi pas de
monsieur va les rendre saint-just qui
sont pour le tout automobile
un regard dans l'avenir dans le
rétroviseur sont ils nous en ont rêvé et
valérie pécresse est en train de le
faire sur le dos des franciliens pendant
la table ronde organisée par la patronne
de la région des propositions à plus
long terme ont été avancées comme la
mise en place du forfait adapté ou d'une
tarification à la demande en fonction de
l'heure ou de la distance quel que soit
l'endroit
par exemple avant demain à septembre
2015 on habitait toujours plus loin et
ont payé plus cher pour un service
inférieur et de mauvaises conditions de
transport
donc là il y a quand même une forme
d'égalité d'unité de solidarité entre
l'ensemble des franciliens
quel que soit l'endroit on prend le
train c'est un choix de raison c'est un
choix de développement
valérie pécresse reste ouverte à un
dialogue avec le gouvernement pour
trouver le financement des 300 millions
d'euros manquants
nous oeuvrons à présent une page
politique dans ce journal wilfried est
riche il nous a rejoint et pour
commencer il sera question de la
dernière séance du conseil
d'agglomération de saint quentin
bonsoir flore année un chiffre pour
commencer 6 6 heures c'est la durée de
ce conseil et d'hier soir ça a été loin
la séance a été longue pas uniquement
raison du nombre de points à l'ordre du
jour les élus des douze communes de
saint quentin en yvelines se sont réunis
dans un climat que vous connaissez il
est particulièrement tendue cela s'est
confirmé une nouvelle fois dès les
premiers échanges entre majorité et
opposition des échanges qui portait
pourtant uniquement sur le contenu même
du règlement intérieur
alors parmi les dossiers qui ont
provoqué de très loin ce des changes
celui du quartier des détiennent de la
verrière petit rappel la verrière porte
un projet de 1800
nouveaux logements autour de la gare
seulement le maire d'elancourt aussi
deuxième vice président de saint quentin
en yvelines a jugé publiquement que la
ville était déjà en échec sur la mixité
sociale que cela ne ferait qu'empirer
les communes dites d'opposition celle de
gauche donc sont particulièrement en
colère le coeur du problème c'est en
fait la conception même de
l'intercommunalité dans quelle mesure
une agglomération peut s'impliquer sur
l'urbanisme d'une commune les avis
divergent mais pour l'instant le maire
d'elancourt a décidé que 50 ne pouvait
plus avoir de responsabilités
d'aménagement regard des rapports
entretenus entre les élus il suspend
donc tous les échanges sur cette
question et ce n'est pas là le seul
point de blocage il était aussi question
d'intervention de la programmation
culturelle et des salles de spectacles
le maire d'elancourt vient récemment de
demandé la déprogrammation d'un
spectacle dans la salle de sa commune
pour le moment géré par l'agglomération
la salle du prisme il juge que le
message porté ne s'adresse pas au plus
grand nombre ne fait pas preuve d'assez
de neutralité et là encore les élus de
gauche sont offusqués hier soir autour
de la conception de la culture mais
aussi sur la question une nouvelle fois
de l'intervention d'un élu petite phrase
du maire de magny les hameaux 50 ans
n'est pas une supra commune qui peut se
permettre d' interférer alors les élus
siégeaient pour la dernière fois avant
les vacances
est-ce que la situation va s'améliorer
ce sera difficile 2017 sera marqué par
la présidentielle et par les
législatives aussi les jeux politiques
vont se poursuivre mais que l'on se
rassure tout de même hier soir des
décisions ont été prises saint-quentin
avance la nouvelle majorité continue
d'afficher une volonté de désendettement
est l'adhésion au syndicat mixte autolib
métropole est actée bientôt des
véhicules en location à disposition au
coin des rues lieu comme à paris et
peut-être aussi d'une manière plus
anecdotique les subventions pour les
associations sportives de santé
culturelles ont aussi quasiment tout
fait l'unanimité malgré quelques
remarques car si wheels tribune
dernières informations politiques elle
concerne les législatives j'estime car
les républicains des yvelines ont d'ores
et déjà désigné leurs candidats dans les
douze circonscriptions de notre
département la liste est connu aucune
surprise les sortants sont réinvestis
françois de mazières maire de versailles
dans la première pascal thévenot aussi
fraîchement élu voici deux mois sur le
secteur de vélizy après le départ de
valérie pécresse pour la région henri
guaino par ailleurs candidat pour la
primaire à la présidentielle brigue
également un nouveau
deux députés tout comme jean frédéric
poisson dans la 10e circonscription dans
la 11e
le maire d'elancourt jean michel
fourgous va tenter de retrouver un poste
qu'il avait perdu la dernière fois face
à benoît hamon en cas de victoire il
devra comme d'autres d'ailleurs choisir
cumul des mandats oblige
en dehors de son poste de maire il est
également conseiller départemental et
puis vous le voyez david douillet c'est
le patron des républicains dans le
département il se représente dans la 12e
circonscription ça c'est pour les
républicains et pour le parti socialiste
il faudra encore attendre un peu la
fédération départementale va lancer les
premières consultations le mois prochain
juste avant les vacances elle les
militants vont devoir ensuite voté en
novembre pour désigner les candidats et
les investitures ne seront connus qu'au
mois de décembre rappelle que le scrutin
se déroulera après la présidentielle
donc ce sera au mois de mai au mois de
juin le ps va d'ici là chercher à
conclure des alliances dès le premier
tour pour essayer de conserver ces deux
postes de députés les socialistes
détiennent de siège aujourd'hui sur les
douze circonscriptions des aigles merci
wilfried nous poursuivons ce journal
avec un déplacement du président de la
république françois hollande est et à
versailles vendredi avant l'hommage aux
policiers de magnanville il a inauguré
le pavillon dufour du château de
versailles
après un vaste chantier de réaménagement
de près de deux ans et demi le nouvelle
aide espace d'accueil espace d'accueil
pardon du public se veut plus
esthétiques et fonctionnels retour sur
cette visite avec fanni briand plus
clair et plus spacieux les visiteurs
emprunteront désormais le nouveau
pavillon dufour pour accéder au château
de versailles
ce vendredi françois hollande l'a
inaugurée et salué cette réussite
esthétique les espaces et steve chen
s'il ya plus la contempler et en même
temps aussi un exploit fonctionnel ce
qu'il fallait
ne rien dénaturer et en même temps faire
en sorte que le public puisse être
encore mieux accueillis
c'est en 2011 que le château de
versailles a confié ses travaux à
l'architecte dominique perrault tout en
respectant l'histoire du château des
matériaux modernes où étaient ajoutés au
pavillon le prévient dufour c'est un
ensemble qui est 18e et 17e et
l'intervention évidemment est une
intervention contemporaine avec la mise
en place d'un grand escalier de marbre
qui va permettre à l'ensemble des
visiteurs de sortir
à l'issue de la visite pour les
rejoindre les jardins une boutique un
auditorium et des annexes se rajoute à
ce bâtiment de 2700 mètres carrés au
premier étage un café restaurant du chef
étoilé alain ducasse ouvrira en
septembre et cette information
concernant la commune de plaisir hier à
la ville a inauguré une nouvelle la
maison des familles camille claudel sa
troisième maison des familles de la
commune en plus de celle de la mosaïque
et flora tristan alors ces structures
sont des espaces ressources pour les
plaisirs wade lieu d'échangé et de
partage entre les habitants de la
commune permettant d'offrir des services
mieux adaptés aux besoins repérés au
sein des différents quartiers parmi
leurs différentes missions
les maisons des familles font de
l'accompagnement du soutien à la
parentalité des actions à destination de
la petite enfance de prévention santé
ainsi que différentes animations et
demain mercredi à 22 juin à 8 heures les
soldes d'été recommence six semaines
attendu par les professionnels les
magasins sont dans les tous derniers
préparatifs et eqt âge sorti des cartons
et mise en rayon selon une étude de
yougov réalisé pour le site marais du
point comme le panier moyen augmenterait
de 55 euros
cette année par rapport à l'année
dernière un reportage à signer mélanie
poté et fanny bourdon quelques articles
sont encore en réserve
cette boutique de prêt-à-porter termine
ses préparatifs elle proposera dès
demain quinze mille pièces à la vente
qu'on anticipe quelques semaines à
l'avancé
on a beaucoup de marchandises
qui sont en carton donc tout ça c'est de
la préparation c'est de l'étiquetage en
amont pour pouvoir être prêt le jour j
fin d'après midi les employés sont sur
le pont pour finaliser la boutique en
période de soldes les effectifs de 8
personnes sont doublés la mauvaise météo
de ces derniers jours n'a pas poussé les
français dans les rayons mais dans ce
magasin pas d'inquiétude pour autant les
gens quand ils veulent acheter des sols
de s'équiper ont pensé à leurs vacances
etc
la météo a l'air voilà ce qu'ils
annoncent en tout cas à l'air plutôt
sympa dont je pense que les gens vont
continuer venir acheter n'est pas tout
si c'est beaucoup de travail manutention
voilà on a des cdd donc voulait former
et c'est donc c'est pas toujours évident
parce qu'on a encore des promos qu'ils
soient en cours jusqu'à ce soir et il
faut leur expliquer comment fonctionne
l'encaissement les étiquetages comment
ça marche
l'année dernière le panier moyen du
consommateur était d'environ 245 euros
les bonnes affaires sont possibles
jusqu'au 2 août il est temps de passer à
présent notre entretien ce soir nous
recevons en plateau murad ali président
de l'association culturelle ali fait des
longs cours est également membre de du
collecte des as de la collecte et
associations musulmanes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et ses
environs on saura vous remercie d'avoir
accepté à notre invitation alors vous
êtes ici ce soir pour réagir notamment
aux attentats de mad movies l'est lundi
dernier donc un couple de fonctionnaires
de police et jessica schneider et jean
baptiste salvin ont été assassinés à
leur domicile par l'art aussi à bâle à
un attentat islamiste été revendiqué par
a déj de nombreuses associations
musulmanes ont exprimé leur soutien
vous-même donc avec le cm soit 118 le
collectif des associations musulmanes à
des îles vinh et le conseil
constitutionnel des musulmans des
yvelines également le simi vous avez
réagi très rapidement
justement après cet événement n'a reçu
de nombreux communiqués pour exprimer
votre soutien oui c'était c'était tout à
fait normal
on a réagi avant tout en tant qu'humain
en tant qu'humain et pas seulement en
tant que musulman
réagir en temps avant tout en tant
qu'humain parce que aucun humain ne peut
accepter ce qui s'est passé donc on
avait déjà réagi aux précédents
événements qui pouvait y avoir par des
communiqués donc nous avons réagi cette
fois ci par un communiqué mais comme je
le disais c'était avant tout en tant
qu'humain et aussi en tant que citoyen
français et c'est plus en soutien aux
familles et face à l'horreur de ce qui
s'est passé que nous avons réagi
nous avons réagi aussi en tant que
musulman parce que et on colle cette
étiquette enfin soit il y aurait des
revendications islamistes
mais d'une manière générale nous
condamnons tout type de violence
que ce soit en france ou à l'étranger
toutes ces violences la sont néfastes et
négatives et nous les condamnons haut et
fort et sans équivoque
maintenant c'est vrai que on peut
regretter de presque toujours avoir à se
justifier
nous français musulmans de ce que une
personne ou une poignée de personnes
peut faire au même si c'est au nom de
l'islam
on ne demande pas à d'autres d'autres
confessions de se justifier quand un
extrémiste parmi eux comme je crois en
finlande tue plus de 100 personnes au
nom d'une religion une très forte
mobilisation à l'association human donc
de mantes la jolie par exemple ont
organisé une marche pour rendre hommage
aux victimes vous dit que vous sentiez
obligé pourtant on a l'impression que
maintenant voilà c'est un presque un
automatisme pour peut-être éviter les
amalgames
c'est un mode c'est un automatisme oui
et non c'est à dire que c'est c'est
nature je dis bien c'est nature chez
l'homme de condamner tout type de
violence
maintenant ce qui est problématique
malheureusement dans la société
française est de plus en plus c'est que
il ya un sentiment que le musulman est
toujours présumé coupable
donc s'il ne dit rien votre sentiment
c'est un ressenti qui nous remontent
souvent qui est d'ailleurs c'est prouvé
si l'on ne dit rien on a souvent
reproché par exemple le musulman à
l'époque de la marche suite au 11
janvier de ne pas être assez présent
donc s'ils ne sont pas là on leur
reproche s'ils réagissent tardivement
il ya suspicion et même là par cette
marche qui est quand même a mobilisé
plusieurs milliers de personnes et qui
est la marche la plus importante fête à
la suite de ce drame
il ya quand même malheureusement des
personnes politiques donc notamment un
député c'est triste et affligeant de
voir cela qui voit là un doute il a un
doute midi sincérité ou duplicité c'est
à dire que même quand on quand les
musulmans se mobilisent et marche comme
ils l'ont fait à mantes la jolie
certaines personnes les considère encore
comme peut-être pas sincère selon vous
il ya une pression vous n'avez peut-être
marre de devoir vous justifiez pas de ça
c'est pas ça c'est que est ce que l'on
demande où est ce que l'on demanderait
dans notre inconscient les mêmes choses
à d'autres personnes d'autres
confessions en france est ce que si tout
simplement regarder cette personne là à
faire un crime horrible avec un couteau
de boucher ou un couteau de cuisine
je suis surpris du bon pas de ce
traitement médiatique parce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'horrible et
clairement il a touché non seulement des
personnes qui représentent l'état qui
protège la population et ça on ne peut
que condamner fermement et sans
équivoque
une fois cela dit moi je suis surpris du
traitement médiatique ou du faible
traitement médiatique de d'événements
qui sont passés quasiment inaperçus
il ya quand même une dizaine de jours
une personne et a été arrêté par les
services de secret secret l'yonne
craignant avec plus de 100 kg
d'explosifs
un armement de guerre plus important que
tout ce qui a été perquisitionné depuis
l'état d'urgence parce que c'est un
événement qui s'est passé en france et
c'est vrai que soul alerte état
d'urgence sont pas s'imaginer que des
événements comme ça ne serait pas arrivé
est-ce que cinq ans
ce qui vous inquiète est ce que vous
avez peur de l'amalgamé simplement
quelque chose qui est inquiétant bien
sûr parce que pour revenir sur cet
événement c'est vrai que ça s'est passé
en france mais c'était un français qui
voulait revenir en france et les
services secrets ukrainiens ont
clairement dit qu'ils envisageaient
d'attaquer notamment des mosquées avec
un arsenal militaire
alors ils avaient peut-être juste comme
chose contre lui le fait qu'il ait un
tee shirt d'un groupuscule identitaire
en france mais je pense est
malheureusement que le traitement
médiatique et bat est même politique de
cet événement là aurait été différent si
cette personne là qui a été arrêté par
les services secrets ukrainiens étaient
de confession musulmane et avait un nom
à consonance arabo-musulmane bien
investis selon vous écoutez je ne sais
pas mais quelqu'un qui a 125 kg de tnt
des lance-roquettes des armes de guerre
et qui arrive en france à la veille ou
au début de l'euro en plein état
d'urgence ça interpelle quelque peu la
communauté musulmane a quand même a
quand même réagi est ce qu'aujourd'hui
peut-être vous avez un message à
diffuser ce que c'est c'est une crainte
que vous ayez d'être tout le temps
montrés du doigt comme ça oui justement
le problème je pense que bien sûr cet
événement est triste affligeant on peut
voir encore aussi qu'il ya une
recrudescence dans le profil de ces
personnes de personnes qui ont quand
même un passé judiciaire assez lourd
c'est ça reste quand même des profils
qui sont récurrents et on peut pas
assimiler les millions de musulmans à
cela et
et actuellement les personnes là souvent
ne se fréquentent pas de mosquées mais
maintenant on met tout le monde dans le
même sac
c'est à dire que quand un responsable
associatif a parlé avec un élu la
question même des lieux de culte devient
une question sensible alors que la
plupart des personnes commettant ce
genre de choses sont des jeunes sans
repères et où peuvent-ils à prendre leur
religion en dehors d'un lieu de culte
décent c'est internet qui prend le
relais il ya deux choses qu'il faut
vraiment auquel on doit tous faire
attention et en français mais
premièrement les médias pour pape vous
parce que je tiens à signaler que je
vous remercie pour l'invitation et les
vous faites un travail remarquable au
niveau local mais il ya certains médias
nationaux et certains politiques qui
doit faire attention à ne pas développer
deux sentiments le sentiment d'injustice
chez certains et le sentiment d'impunité
parce que certains peuvent banaliser des
paroles très lourde même des élus voire
des ministres des paroles clairement
islamophobes et des profonds propres aux
pieds des propos racistes pardon qui se
banalise et ça crée un gouffre dans la
société française est ce que l'on
reproche souvent aux musulmans ce
communautarisme paradoxalement on est en
train de le nourrir
est-ce que vous souhaiteriez par exemple
être associés à des initiatives
politiques pour justement travaillé sur
apporter peut-être des solutions
apportées aussi votre vision sur voilà
des on parle souvent voix de deux loups
solitaires pour essayer de d'encadrer ou
peut-être d'aider ces personnes par
rapport à par rapport aux initiatives
politiques faut rappeler quand même que
l'islam est la deuxième religion de
france
elle est malheureusement trop souvent
abordé actuellement dans les médias
uniquement par le biais et la lucarne
des faits divers il ya encore plus d'une
dizaine d'années il y avait même des
programmes culturels qui s'appelait les
nuits du ramadan dans certaines chaînes
actuellement pas un mot ni des plus
hauts représentants de l'état ni du
gouvernement pour souhaiter un ramadhan
aux musulmans lorsqu'il ya le maire de
londres qui a été élu on en a fait toute
une polémique en france parce qu'ils
étaient de confession ou d'origine
musulmane mais ça n'existe pas dans
d'autres pays cela et par rapport à
l'initiative politique je pense que oui
c'est aux politiques de prendre en
compte toute la société
c'est pas aux musulmans d'aller chercher
les politiques vous messieurs
sinon vous avez vous sollicité vous
accepteriez accusé de travailler de
peut-être d'apporter un éclairage
différent
écoutez pour l'instant on n'a jamais été
sollicité et on a toujours été citoyen
on a fait des communiqués quand on
pouvait on a ouvert nos portes au niveau
du collectif des associations du zune
années soixante dix huit le 418 on a
fait un dîner annuel qui sera renouvelée
parce que ça vient pas d'une demande
c'est pour nous quelque chose qui va de
soi une dernière question avant de
terminer cet entretien est ce que vous
allez organiser des initiatives
initiatives au niveau de la leaf le
rapport au ramadan ou peut-être une
initiative de solidarité bientôt alors
moi en tant que président d'alif sur
elancourt
depuis que je suis président il ya
quelques mois ça fait la deuxième fois
nous organisons tout nous organisons
toujours un iftar donc un repas de
rupture du jeûne que nous partageons
avec nos concitoyens
d'autres confessions des confessions
chrétienne ou juive et aussi avec les
officiels donc la plupart des officiels
avec qui nous avons des rapports sont
invités certains pourront venir d'autres
non mais en tout cas la démarche est
toujours une démarche d'ouverture de la
part des musulmans vers les non
musulmans en france
merci d'être venus en plateau et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci à vous
toutes autres sujets nous passons aux
sports à présent l'équipe de football
américain des templiers d'elancourt a
fêté ce samedi ses 30 ans avec une
grande fête au complexe sportif europe
les joueurs le staff et les anciens
joueurs se sont retrouvés pour pathé
khaled pour partager leurs souvenirs et
leurs expériences sur le club
retour sur cette fête avait clamé
l'année potté est inutile et demi
d'euros trente ans ça se fête les
templiers d'elancourt passer le cap de
la trentaine au complexe sportif europe
avec une grande manifestation des petits
matchs des démonstrations de
cheerleaders et une exposition photos
retraçant l'histoire du club et est
organisée ce samedi en présence du staff
des joueurs et des anciens séquence
émotion pour les templiers
qu'est ce que çà mau sur wii mais
effectivement que j'ai pris 30 ans
puisque
j'étais leur premier entraînement des
cormorans qui sont devenus par la suite
layton les templiers
donc voilà ça nous rajeunit pas mais
c'est très belle fête aujourd'hui voilà
on retrouve les anciens à toulouse a
pris ton temps il n'y a pas que moi un
plaisir de faire partie de cette famille
une envie de relève
envie de prendre le relais et de
produits succéder à nos coachs plein de
souvenirs plein plein d'amitié plein de
voyage et voir des gens que j'ai pas
revu depuis
20 25 voire 30 ans tout début et qui
vont arriver les uns après les autres a
au fil de la journée
en trente ans le club à évoluer la
structure qui a connu six présidents des
dizaines de coach est passé de 45
adhérents à 270 footballeur américain
aujourd'hui des templiers se sont
également professionnaliser pour faire
partie des meilleures équipes de
l'hexagone
avant c'était un jeu on va dire qu'on se
taper dessus se retrouve sans trop
savoir pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup plus technique physique
les gars ils font de la musculation de
trois fois par semaine voilà on est
vraiment dans les standards de football
américain tel qu'on peut le l'approché
aux états unis on se rapproche de plus
en plus à l'époque nord à l'époque
c'était on se rentrer dedans avec un
ballon au milieu et puis voilà quoi
prochain objectif pour les 30 prochaines
années des templiers faire remonter
l'équipe une en première division et
l'installer dans le top 3 des équipes
françaises en développant en parallèle
la formation des jeunes sport automobile
à présent se ne fait pas les 24 heures
du mans à maurepas mais presque dimanche
19 juin le modélisme workpad club
organisait sa course annuelle de
voitures radiocommandées une compétition
régionale ouverte aux amateurs de petits
bolides eux tout terrain termites et
même électrique des lits commodes en
moins les pilotes se sont affrontés
toute la journée sur le circuit du
modélisme maurepas club des buttes
débutants ou confirmés 72 participants
ont fait le déplacement
la matinée était consacrée aux
qualifications et l'après midi aux demi
finales et aux finales des différentes
catégories
le gagnant les gagnants de la course ont
décroché leur ticket pour concombre et
pour concourir en coupe de france un
loisir accessible à tous mais qui
demande une technique un peu
particulière on écoute le responsable de
la section tout terrain du modélisme
maurepas club
la grosse difficulté c'est qu'on pilote
une voiture mais on n'est pas dedans
quand on est dedans on sent que ça
glisse on peut contrôler braqué
facilement l'adhérence où ça là il faut
tout anticiper le seul avantage c'est
qu'on voit un petit peu ce qui se passe
devant plus facilement ce qui se passe
derrière une voiture pour regarder dans
les rétroviseurs fait plus d pas plus
compliqué l'objectif c'est que tu faire
plaisir quand on commence on est
débutant il ya pas vraiment y'a pas
vraiment d'objectif je veux dire
l'objectif déjà d'essayer de finir près
de se faire plaisir surtout à quoi c'est
des petites voitures mais ça demande
beaucoup de beaucoup d'entretien
beaucoup de beaucoup de voile a beaucoup
de coûts d'entretien beaucoup de temps
voilà c'est la grosse difficulté d'avoir
une voiture qui puisse soutenir les
banques comme ça c'est vraiment
difficile et après beaucoup de passions
surtout et c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivis tout de suite
vous avez rendez vous avec à nicolas
acquirent le vide pour le 7-8 société
objet du débat quels remèdes pour les
déserts médicaux font je vous retrouve
demain pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 le
journal je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée